Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Kim Mills. Speaking of Psychology is a podcast for anyone with an interest in the science of psychology. We talk to psychological researchers, practitioners, and educators about any and every aspect of psychology and its application to the world around us. Dr. Sharut Guntucku is a postdoctoral researcher in multimedia computing, working at the Penn Medicine Center for Digital Health. His research aims to leverage large-scale social media image and text data to model social health outcomes and psychological traits. He also works closely with the World Well-Being Project at the Positive Psychology Center at the University of Pennsylvania. Before joining the Penn Medicine Center, Dr. Guntuku completed his PhD studies on modeling
您好，欢迎收听由美国心理学会制作的播客《心理学谈话》。我是主持人金·米尔斯。《心理学谈话》是一档面向所有对心理学科学感兴趣的听众的播客。我们与心理学研究人员、从业者和教育工作者探讨心理学的方方面面及其在现实世界中的应用。Sharut Guntuku博士是一位多媒体计算领域的博士后研究员，目前在宾夕法尼亚大学医学中心数字健康中心工作。他的研究旨在利用大规模社交媒体图像和文本数据来模拟社会健康结果和心理特征。他还与宾夕法尼亚大学积极心理学中心的“世界幸福项目”密切合作。在加入宾夕法尼亚大学医学中心之前，Guntuku博士完成了他的博士研究，课题是关于建模
users' personality and multimedia preferences at the School of Computer Science and Engineering at Nanyang Technological University in Singapore. He also worked on facial expression recognition while interning at Panasonic. Thank you for joining us today. Thank you very much for inviting me. So let's start by talking about the research that you presented here. Can you explain what you did, I know it had to do with Twitter and attention deficit hyperactivity disorder. So we were looking at people who post that they had a diagnosis of ADHD on Twitter, and we got something like 1,400 people with the self-diagnosis of ADHD, and we analyzed how their linguistic patterns vary with a control group.
用户在新加坡南洋理工大学计算机科学与工程学院的多媒体偏好和个性。他还在松下实习期间从事过面部表情识别的研究。感谢您今天加入我们。非常感谢您的邀请。那么，让我们从您在这里展示的研究开始谈起。您能解释一下您做了什么吗？我知道这与Twitter和注意力缺陷多动障碍（ADHD）有关。我们观察了那些在Twitter上发布自己被诊断出患有ADHD的用户，我们找到了大约1400名自称患有ADHD的人，并分析了他们的语言模式与对照组有何不同。
Are they posting more at night? Are they posting more about being anxious? Are they posting more about being stressed? and how does their personality vary when compared to the control group? And some of the findings that we get from Twitter, it's really interesting, and they sort of confirm existing clinical studies on ADHD, and there are others which sort of give new hypothesis, which can then be tested in an actual clinical study.
他们是否在晚上发布更多内容？他们是否发布更多关于焦虑的内容？他们是否发布更多关于压力的内容？与对照组相比，他们的个性有何不同？我们从Twitter上得到的一些发现非常有趣，它们在某种程度上证实了现有的关于ADHD的临床研究，还有一些则提出了新的假设，这些假设可以在实际的临床研究中进行验证。
For instance, a lot of studies have shown that anxiety is a comorbital. bit conditioned with ADHD. And we find a lot of people using a lot of anxiety-related words on Twitter. And we also see that people are posting a lot at night. So people with ADHD are posting a lot at night between, say, 12 a.m. and 6 a.m. when people are supposed to be sleeping. And this sort of suggests that Twitter is giving them the instant gratification that people with ADHD want. So you post a tweet and you get instant comments. Yeah. So that's, so this platform is giving you that opportunity or that right venue to trigger your different traits.
例如，许多研究表明焦虑是ADHD的共病。我们发现很多人在Twitter上使用了大量与焦虑相关的词汇。我们还发现人们在晚上发布了很多内容。患有ADHD的人在晚上，比如凌晨12点到早上6点，也就是人们应该睡觉的时候，发布了大量内容。这表明Twitter为他们提供了ADHD患者所渴望的即时满足感。你发一条推文，就能得到即时的评论。是的。所以这个平台为你提供了那种机会或合适的场所来触发你不同的特质。
And that's something that ADHD people would be looking for. Yes. They want that instant answer to whatever it is that they're thinking about at that time. There's something particular about people with ADHD that they'd be awake at those hours. Did you know that going in? No, we didn't. So we had no clue what times they would be posting. We had a general idea that maybe they'll be posting more
而这正是ADHD患者所追求的。是的。他们想要对当时脑海中想到的任何事情得到即时的回应。ADHD患者在这些时间保持清醒有什么特别之处吗？您在研究开始时知道这一点吗？不，我们不知道。所以我们根本不知道他们会在什么时间发布内容。我们有一个大概的想法，也许他们会发布更多
when compared to the control group, and that's something we found. But we didn't really know when they'll be posting. For instance, it was completely new for us and even a collaborator on the paper who actually sees patients with ADHD. And he was like, oh, this is interesting. Because often patients who comment to him, they never report or they seldom report that they were up until 4 a.m.
与对照组相比，这是我们发现的。但我们真的不知道他们会在什么时候发布。例如，这对我们甚至对论文的合作者来说都是全新的，他实际上是看ADHD患者的医生。他说，哦，这很有趣。因为经常有患者向他反馈，他们从不或很少报告说他们熬夜到凌晨4点。
because we don't really keep track of time that well. But then if you have a way to summarize the activity on social media and give that to clinician, that's where we are trying to take this forward in terms of providing clinicians the right feedback about patients. So then what they go back and ask their patients with ADHD, do you have trouble sleeping and they can then help treat that? Yes. Is there anything about the medication that somebody with ADHD might be taking, is going to keep them awake at night? Frankly, I don't know the answer to that
因为我们对时间的记录并不那么准确。但如果你有一种方法可以总结社交媒体上的活动并将其提供给临床医生，这就是我们试图推进的方向，即为临床医生提供关于患者的正确反馈。那么他们回去询问ADHD患者时，会问“你有睡眠问题吗”，然后他们就可以帮助治疗了吗？是的。ADHD患者服用的药物是否会导致他们晚上保持清醒？坦率地说，我不知道答案，
because I'm not an expert in ADHD, but we did see a lot of language related to weed, so smoking weed, for instance. And we were surprised. Why are people posting about smoking weed when they have ADHD? And then this collaborator of ours said, oh, this is something that I always see.
因为我不是ADHD方面的专家，但我们确实看到了很多与大麻相关的语言，例如吸食大麻。我们感到很惊讶。为什么患有ADHD的人会发布关于吸食大麻的内容？然后我们的这位合作者说，哦，这是我经常看到的情况。
People are using weed to self-medicate. Oh, okay, that makes sense. Yeah. So how did you get this cohort? I mean, how would you know that just because somebody is on Twitter and says he or she has ADHD that that's true? So there is no way of formally confirming if they had an official diagnosis of ADHD. But there are a few studies which looked at depression-related tweets.
人们使用大麻进行自我治疗。哦，好的，这说得通。是的。那么你们是如何获得这个群体的？我的意思是，你怎么知道仅仅因为某人在Twitter上说他或她患有ADHD，这就是真的呢？目前没有办法正式确认他们是否拥有ADHD的官方诊断。但有一些研究观察了与抑郁症相关的推文。
For instance, I was diagnosed with depression. And then they asked people to, or rather, to independent assessors, to, go through these tweets and then give their assessment of whether these tweets look genuine or not. And those studies report high inter-rater agreeability. But then that's about the confirmation that we have so far about the data that we have collected. But going forward, especially with depression, we have data from multiple sources. For instance, we have a lot of people who have self-reported their depression diagnosis on Twitter.
例如，“我被诊断出患有抑郁症”。然后他们要求人们，或者更确切地说是两名独立的评估员，去浏览这些推文，然后给出他们对这些推文看起来是否真实的评估。这些研究报告了很高的一致性。但这只是我们目前对所收集数据确认程度的了解。但展望未来，特别是在抑郁症方面，我们有来自多个来源的数据。例如，我们有很多在Twitter上自述患有抑郁症的人。
And we have also asked a lot of people to take depression screening questionnaires like CESD or BDI and they have shared their social media data with us. So they have consented to share them with us. And we also have at Penn Medicine Center for Digital Health, we have people who have clinical records of depression. So we have these huge variety of data sources. And now we have a way to compare which data is reliable in terms of whether the that we collect based on these self-reports, if we build a model on that and test it on the
我们还要求很多人填写抑郁症筛查问卷，如CESD或BDI，他们与我们分享了他们的社交媒体数据。所以他们同意与我们分享这些数据。在宾夕法尼亚大学医学中心数字健康中心，我们也有患有抑郁症的临床记录的人。所以我们有各种各样的数据源。现在我们有一种方法来比较哪些数据是可靠的，即如果我们基于这些自述构建一个模型，并在
clinical diagnosis, does it really work? And the note here is that even the clinical diagnosis themselves are not really robust because the idea of diagnosing somebody for these mental health conditions, it takes at least two or three hours. And often the diagnosis in the clinical setting in the primary care are not that rigid or that accurate. So there is some fuzziness in the ground truth. Interesting. So did you get permission from everybody to use their, you know, follow them on Twitter? So we were not following anyone on Twitter. We were just using the Twitter API to look at public tweets. So anyone who
临床诊断上进行测试，它真的有效吗？这里需要注意的是，即使是临床诊断本身也不是非常稳健的，因为诊断某人患有这些心理健康状况的想法至少需要两到三个小时。而且通常在初级保健的临床环境中，诊断并不那么严格或准确。所以基本事实中存在一些模糊性。有趣。那么你们是否获得了每个人的许可来使用他们的，你知道，在Twitter上关注他们？我们没有在Twitter上关注任何人。我们只是使用Twitter API来查看公开推文。所以任何
posts on Twitter, the data is public, unless they set it to be private. And we don't go into the private tweets because we don't have access. But we have IRB at the university which controls what we do with the data and how we store the data and so on. So we are using mostly public tweets and we don't follow or we don't communicate or engage with the participants that we're actually recruiting. So what are the next steps now based on what you learned? How does this get applied? So here it's multifold actually.
在Twitter上发布内容的人，数据都是公开的，除非他们将其设置为私密。我们不会进入私密推文，因为我们无法访问。但我们在大学有机构审查委员会（IRB），它控制着我们如何处理数据、如何存储数据等。所以我们主要使用公开推文，我们不会关注，也不会与我们实际招募的参与者进行交流或互动。那么根据你们所学到的，接下来的步骤是什么？这如何应用？实际上是多方面的。
The first thing we're looking at is if we can develop some feedback apps so that you take our survey and then can we give you as a user or rather the person who is thinking, taking the survey, can we give them some feedback about how they have been using social media the last week or the last month? Here are the words that you are posting on social media last week and you've been swearing a lot, perhaps you've not noticed, and you've been posting a lot at night. Looks like you should keep your phones away before you sleep or at least one hour before you sleep.
我们正在研究的第一件事是，我们是否可以开发一些反馈应用程序，让你参与我们的调查，然后作为用户，或者更确切地说是正在考虑参与调查的人，我们可以给你一些关于你过去一周或一个月如何使用社交媒体的反馈吗？这是你上周在社交媒体上发布的词汇，你一直在说脏话，也许你没有注意到，而且你晚上发布了很多内容。看起来你应该在睡觉前把手机收起来，或者至少在睡觉前一小时收起来。
So we are looking at some of these feedback mechanisms to the user of social media. And we're also working with clinicians to find out a way to give this data, to summarize this data and give them in an actionable format. What made you choose ADHD out of all the possible syndromes that you could be looking at? So ADHD, unlike depression, unlike, say, anxiety, is not really well studied in the literature. And some of its manifestations are still being discovered. So we thought social media being the, you know, it gives you the in the moment feel for users. So we thought social media will give us some of these manifestations which are not yet discovered in the clinical setting.
所以我们正在研究一些针对社交媒体用户的反馈机制。我们也在与临床医生合作，寻找一种方法来提供这些数据，总结这些数据并以可操作的格式提供给他们。在所有你可以研究的综合征中，是什么让你选择了ADHD？因为ADHD与抑郁症、焦虑症不同，在文献中并没有得到很好的研究。它的一些表现形式仍在被发现中。所以我们认为社交媒体，你知道，它为你提供了用户当下的感受。所以我们认为社交媒体会给我们提供一些在临床环境中尚未发现的表现形式。
And it will help us generate some of the hypotheses which we can go and test back. Great. Well, that's all very interesting. Thank you so much for being with us today. Thanks a lot. It is great. It is fun talking to you. Speaking of psychology is part of the APA podcast network.
这将有助于我们生成一些可以回去验证的假设。太棒了。这非常有趣。非常感谢您今天来到这里。非常感谢。这很棒。和你交谈很愉快。《心理学谈话》是美国心理学会播客网络的一部分。
which includes other great podcasts such as APA Journal's Dialogue about the latest and most exciting psychological research and progress notes, which discusses the practice of psychology. You can find all APA podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, and wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speakingofpsychology.org, to listen to more episodes and see more resources on the topics we discuss. I'm Kim Mills with the American Psychological Association, and this is Speaking of Psychology.
其中包括其他很棒的播客，例如《美国心理学会期刊对话》，讨论最新和最令人兴奋的心理学研究；以及《进度记录》，讨论心理学实践。你可以在iTunes、Stitcher以及任何你获取播客的地方找到所有美国心理学会的播客。你也可以访问我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org，收听更多剧集并查看我们讨论主题的更多资源。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯，这是《心理学谈话》。
You know, There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你知道，这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。